hey guys today it is the 15th of
December my name is Justin um watching
games buddy activision has gone hard
with the micro transactions today and
the first game to get hit with the
controversial feature is destiny Bungie
is now offering people a paid boost to
level 25 if they'd rather get those
levels instantly instead of putting
hours into the game that they presumably
just bought you know to play the games
current level cap is at 40 and from
there a secondary levelling system based
around armor and weapon strength comes
into play a boost costs a whopping 30 US
dollars by comparison pay for your World
of Warcraft character to hit the level
100 cap costs sixty dollars when the
taken King arrived it came with one free
character boost just like this one since
Bungie wanted to ensure that everyone
had the chunk to play it and you needed
to be level 25 to get started with that
content this level boost is the newest
addition to Destiny's pre-existing
microtransactions letting you buy
in-game silver currency which lets you
buy things like amongst and various
cosmetic items including new gear for
Sparrow racing league Activision didn't
stop the microtransaction train there
though because as it happens call of
duty black ops 3 is the next stop the
games black market store was updated
today with a bunch of new items you can
buy through supply drops on ps4 xbox one
and pc the items include the butterfly
knife brass knuckles taunts new body and
head variants and extra slot packs among
other things for both multiplayer and
Zombies mode while these items can
eventually be obtained by playing the
game you can grab them instantly by
spending call of duty points which you
can buy with your real-world dulles
Activision is giving out one-time gifts
of 200 code points for a limited time
but if you want to buy them they'll run
you two dollars for 200 right up to
forty dollars for 5000 points finally
today Kajima appears to be launching a
new studio with some former kijima
products
stop a translation of an article from
Japanese publication Nikkei suggest that
Kojima has indeed left Konami according
to unnamed sources the last we'd heard
from the konami code masago was that the
publisher vodka jima from attending the
game awards to accept an award metal
gear solid 5 now it appears he may be in
the process of establishing his own
independent studio the article also
suggests that kojima is in talks with
sony to have the new studio's first game
debut on playstation what that game
might be is still under wraps let me
know down in the comments what you think
about the slew of division
microtransactions and be sure to head to
games that we've got stories on GTA 5
new free updates and the sales of the
Xbox one elite controller that is
everything I have for you today but we
shall leave me your thoughts down in
that comment section and I will catch
you again tomorrow
you